hey what's up guys it's Rob I am back
from the dead and I have a lot of cool
stuff that I'd like to share with you in
this video you know my hair gets really
long and it's starting to get out of
control people have been walking up to
me in the street like yo man are you
Elvis I'm like thank you thank you very
much uh hmm I figure since I haven't put
out a video in a little while as you
know sort of my punishment I think I'm
gonna try to chop it off myself with
these scissors here goes ready I'm gonna
take this and I'm gonna chop that okay
there it is all right
oh my god I gotta sneeze hey oh excuse
me
well I guess that works also Rob got
happy he got a new haircut so he jumped
up in the air and didn't come back down
or go anywhere well that is partly true
I did jump up and down after I got my
new haircut except I didn't stay up in
the air I fell down and not very softly
ah poweriso jumping stilts great workout
it can definitely be very dangerous as I
just found out
I'm just kidding I didn't fall I was
just practicing my push-ups on the
jumping stilts whoo-hoo so these are
called jumping stilts and they have a
little base here and they have an area
where you can step on and you can strap
your leg in they're really fun they can
be really dangerous so you always have
to wear a helmet know that protective
gear that I was wearing in the video I
actually bought these on eBay after I
saw a video on YouTube you can just
YouTube jumping stilts and you'll get
more information on them if you want to
check them out I now have a store at
district lines I'm going to have a link
in the video description and this is my
new t-shirt that I'm actually wearing it
says can you solve rob cube it's
supposed to kind of look like a Rubik's
Cube I got the idea from it because one
of my subscribers submitted a photo on
my Facebook page Thank You Julius so I
turned that into a whole bunch of
different squares and I kind of just
made this shirt from it so if you guys
want to you know get these buy these you
can check out my store that would be
awesome I've been meaning to do a
giveaway with some cool stuff and I do
have some extra shirts so when I do that
these will definitely be given away as
well as you guys have probably seen on
my channel I have the little Rob's world
banner up top but I never really say
anything about Rob's world in my videos
until now
big thanks to Jorge Farfan he is on
youtube at cyber toons he's done a lot
of intros and animations for a lot of
the big youtubers and he does really
amazing work I also got this but
unfortunately I don't know where you
guys can buy it it's kind of cool with
the lights off so I'm gonna have to do
that now to show you guys how it works
welcome to Rob's world what world maybe
I could rap but I still got to learn to
beatbox
if you want to see some cool stuff check
out
pita pot I'd also like to give a big
thanks to Vick he sent me this awesome
boomerang he calls it the comrades
boomerang and he actually made this
himself let me show you how it works
Vicks YouTube username is super good
deal and it definitely is a good deal
because he gives away two boomerangs
every month to two of his subscribers in
a contest so be sure to check out his
channel and subscribe if you want to win
one you guys know that I go to dental
school recently it's been really busy I
have a lot of work to do seeing a lot of
patients I really would love it if
YouTube was my full-time job but
unfortunately it isn't I try my best to
make videos when I can just I get
frustrated sometimes I'll be sitting
there on camera and just wind up arguing
with myself I am Rob number one hey
everyone and I'm Rob number two you're
Rob number two yeah I am Robin whispers
I just drop that about this well you can
find out whatever you want no one you
know oh really
I just bought a green screen not long
ago and I've been messing around with it
I still need to work on the lighting a
little bit that was just something that
I had fun with one other thing that I
had fun with during the holidays that I
like to show you guys sometime soon was
this if you do want to see me make a
tutorial on it leave me a comment below
and I'll be sure to do it I just got
back from Spring Break last week I went
for a week to Nevada with my buddy rich
you know his YouTube channel you can
find it right there I went to Zion
National Park and just the scenery and
everything just helped me get in touch
with my inner nature
as you can see here is a native squirrel
in Mount Zion park it has sort of a dark
rustic colored skin coat and he's going
into a little domicile there which is
that small rock enclosed and it's also
like it's a bottle like a stump of a
tree as you can see he's climbing up
he's looking for his mate and they go
see what's wrong keep a knee
he's gonna attack run run like the
dickens they put their tail of luck that
is because they are you're actually
warning off predators or anything else
who might be chasing them so it's a very
nice sign flipped kind of expert that's
cool oh shoot
soon feed the wild animals remember
father wild get away from my bush I have
a lot of video footage that I took from
that trip but instead of putting it on
my main channel I'm probably gonna
uploaded to my Rob's phone channel that
you can find by clicking on this link up
here check it out if you're not already
subscribed subscribe I know it's kind of
dead right now I haven't uploaded in a
while but I'm gonna start uploading more
videos there as for the YouTube on the
rise competition that I mentioned at the
end of my last video my friend the
portrait art did actually win with help
of logo so great job Rob's world
citizens I really appreciate your
support that you've given my channel I
know it's been kind of hard the last
couple of months you know with my
schedule and with me not uploading
videos as regularly as a lot of other
YouTube partners who do it every week
that is eventually my goal to be able to
upload a new video at least once every
two weeks and it will eventually happen
so if you stick with me you know you
won't be let down I really appreciate
all your help all your support
and thanks for subscribing I hope you
guys enjoy the video and here are some
of the comments at the end of my last
video
raps warble book world